sophomores the assignment was to write
to a role model someone you admire miss
miles here to tell us who you wrote to
Anton Vincent the dictator you found
evidence on their computers yes big Dino
have computers and then how did you know
they were traitors
you said they were sir I admire his
style
dear Tatiana your letters have been a
welcome respite from my struggles there
is a rebel faction that wants to behead
me there is no one I can trust
ah I can totally relate my mom is having
an affair with her creepy boss my school
is ruled by some Mean Girls that call
themselves slushies and the guy I'm into
is a Jesus Freak I'm sorry I don't know
why I did that
sometimes I feel like you're the only
one who gets me communist dictator Anton
Vincent has been ousted and still
unaccounted for
you're smaller than I imagined you're
older I'm delivering you fine but you
need a disguise this is me
please don't be mad I was gonna tell you
Monica child molester is a dictator he
is a political refugee completely
harmless is a horrible person sorry I
got the wrong man you have power you
don't know how to wield it
TV for you to see rebel never accepts
the rebel charges and the moment is
right disrupt the slushy sow with
decisive action you must have the
courage to do what you believe in even
hurts the ones that you love
I'm proud of you why you became the
rebel
you
[Applause]
you